bonjour michel bonjour merci d'être avec
nous dans cette matinale de rtl france
dès lundi pour parler de ces
mobilisations du week end à on l'a vu
les gilet jaune depuis deux semaines
maintenant reprennent reprennent le
terrain à travers ces manifestations de
rue que recherchent exactement selon
vous ces manifestants gilet jaune et
anti passe je pense qu'on peut même
aller plus loin que convergence et
parler du véritable fusion entre les
antilles parce
les gilet jaune les défenseurs du
pouvoir d'achat et d'une manière
générale j'ai envie de dire les
défenseurs du droit de vivre tout
simplement parce que il ya quand même
une montée préoccupante de la pauvreté
dans ceux dans ce pays qui donc que
débouche sur une insécurité économique
ça me fait penser un peu je dirais à la
situation des états unis la pauvreté
elle est là mais on finit par ne plus la
voir ce qui est évidemment le contraire
d'une démocratie bien pensé je crois que
la pauvreté est un digne de la
démocratie
alors il est évident que tous ces
manifestants notamment ceux qui
défendent le droit de ne pas
subir le pass sanitaire si l'on si l'on
peut dire parce que c'est quand même une
sanction des 10 e pour les non et non
vaccinés eh bien je crois que l'on
cherche une sécurité et une sécurité
économique et social et puis bien sûr
parce que ce sont les mêmes personnes
selon vous
quand on regarde les cortèges hier donc
afficher anti pas s'envoyer surtout des
pancartes sur le pouvoir d'achat 1 ce
qui montre bien encore une fois qu'il ya
pas les uns à côté des autres qui a les
uns et les autres qui défendent je pense
je crois ce thème qui est aujourd'hui
fédérateur c'est celui du c'est celui du
pouvoir d'achat alors maintenant chacun
donne la sécurité sanitaire qui est
aussi recherché un sens différent pour
certains la sécurité passe par la
vaccination et le pass sanitaires pour
d'autre part la non vaccination donc
c'est qu'on appelle les anti vaccins et
par le refus du pass du pass sanitaire
la colère peut-elle grandir selon vous
dans les semaines à venir notamment avec
l arrivée de l'est et évidemment les
problèmes de chauffage que l'on connaît
vous savez depuis le début du mouvement
des gilets jaunes de 17 novembre 2018
très exactement
la colère n'a jamais disparu c'était une
colère sourde 1 qui avait lieu
effectivement dans des endroits non
visibles mais les gilets jaunes ont
toujours été là sur le terrain à
défendre encore une fois cette société
qui les prive des droits les plus
élémentaires
donc ça va être un enjeu important de
savoir si cette colère va enfler alors
ça va dépendre évidemment des coûts des
matières premières des coûts des denrées
alimentaires
donc si tout continue à augmenter comme
on peut malheureusement le redoute et il
n'y a aucune raison pour que ces
manifestations du samedi ne se poursuive
pas et n'enfle pas donc à la mesure
encore une fois des souffrances endurées
par des millions de français et on voit
le gouvernement qui fait tout pour
essayer de répondre à cette contestation
est à cette hausse du prix des
carburants avec ce chèque dit de
l'inflation 200 euros donnés aux plus
précaires est le président macron joue
sa candidature la cie le mouvement
prenait davantage d'ampleur je
reprendrai ses propos
des propres lille a bien dit qu'il
pouvait y avoir des circonstances qui
ferait qui pourrait ne pas se présenter
un renvoie donc à ces déclarations un
peu un peu anciennes il est évident
qu'une explosion sociale qui reste
malgré tout une hypothèse quand même
solide aujourd'hui 1 pourrait brouiller
complètement les cartes de cette
élection présidentielle ils savent
qu'aujourd'hui emmanuel macron elle
chéquier donc il a de quoi répondre à
cette contestation voilà alors est
évident qu'aujourd'hui il suffit
évidemment d'annoncé sans regarder si on
a le financement derrière bon mais il
est évident que les gens ne sont pas
dupes 1 100 euros en une seule fois pour
passer tout un automne déjà froid et un
hiver qui risquent de l'être comme celui
de l'an passé ça ça risque encore une
fois de remettre cette question du
pouvoir d'achat sur le devant de la
scène une dernière question à michel
certains dénoncent le coup d'état
permanent avec l'ol en position et la
prolongation de ce pass and i ter qui
pourrait être activée à n'importe quel
moment comment doit-on le comprendre
écoutez moi je pense qu'il serait
peut-être temps de faire une pause ils
passent sanitaires alors je sais bien
qu'on est dans un contexte où on nous
parle d'un rebond de l'épidémie mais je
crois qu'il faut faire confiance aux
français ils sont capables effectivement
d'aller dans un café de se protéger avec
des gestes des gestes-barrières donc
peut-être qu'une pause de ce pass
sanitaires seraient bienvenues
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup mais celle
fils pour votre analyse ce matin